[Music]
let's talk about web therapy uh this is
an excellent show uh and it's it's a
great
format for a show great idea for show uh
you play i'm just a bad therapist right
a therapist whose concept is you don't
want to talk to people for very long
isn't that right not for for three
minutes yeah and not in person right
over the web and uh you're getting a lot
of fun people to do it you were nice
enough to ask me to do it i had a blast
you were fantastic well thank you very
much it was very it was a lot of fun and
there's a lot of improvising and uh
terrific people are doing it we have a a
clip
uh here from i believe this might be
actually the one that i'm in oh yeah i
don't know if it needs much of a setup i
know that i've got a complaint and i've
somehow
uh i i've got a complaint i don't know
how much we want to give away all right
but i think i'm feeling uh mad at a
co-worker right about something and i
and also i think we need to say though
that fiona my character has no idea who
you are no idea who i am and she does i
mean she does at this point but she
really yeah she she doesn't she doesn't
know she doesn't care and i'm
kind of hurt by that let's take a look
at this clip from web therapy
my point is it's his job to laugh it up
and sometimes he makes his own jokes the
other night we had a very attractive
actress on the show olivia wilde i don't
know who that is big star and she came
on the show and our set is smaller than
it appears on television okay and uh she
walked out and she said this is smaller
than it appears and i was just about to
say that's what my wife said on our
honeymoon
uh and uh just as i was about to say
that andy said yeah that's what his wife
said on their honeymoon
why did it was very funny but she didn't
laugh when i said it
well i just picture andy saying it and
it's with his wife so i don't know i
don't know why
[Applause]
you're getting uh
meryl streep
is doing an episode she did the first
two of the first two first two yeah
fantastic and almost
as good as you were
kind of not kidding i mean
she i mean she is remarkable yes yes i
like the kind of not kidding yeah she's
meryl streep yeah and she's you know you
don't need me to tell you like this new
discovery you know
you gotta check out this street kid
she's going places
check it out give her a chance you guys
she's on her way
who else you have uh uh who else is
doing it i know brian julia
louis-dreyfus she's fantastic she's
amazing and david schumer will be on
around when you're starting to appear on
the show no david schwimmer
okay
which one
i'm sure i've got the better position
there you were fantastic you were the
only person who's done the show that
played a version of himself like no one
else has that's called not being able to
act
i got an idea i'll play
conan o'brien
it's very hard though to be yourself
convincingly no it's not
it's time to be someone else you were
listening and you were fantastic well
thank you thank you john the writer
director was blown away he's like well
he can act we're going to take away all
the nice stuff you're saying all right
we're going to cut this out of the show
people don't buy it they don't like it
we don't want to hear that about cody